♪ ♫ ♬ [Top 10 Intro] ♪ ♫ ♬
Need motivation? What's a Top 10? Good evening.
Hey it's Evan Carmichael and this channel was created to help you overcome the number one challenge that is holding you back. A lack of belief in yourself.
You watch these videos because you know there's something greater inside you as well. You've got Michael Jordan level talent at something.
So get ready to change the story that you're telling yourself. Control your thoughts and stop wasting your time with Sam Harris and my take on his Top 10 Rules of Success to give you the belief that you need.
Ok let's kick it off with rule number one. Change the story you tell yourself.
The normal range of psychological suffering you know not clinical depression but just feeling like you know life sucks and you're a failure and there's nothing you know it's like you're just it's you're stuck.
That is a story of telling yourself a story. You're thinking and you can either become more and more mindful of that and interrupt that more and more.
And or and it should be and you can reframe this continually and tell yourself a better story. You can actually just engineer you know you can change the code that you're you know running moment to moment.
And I mean just a very simple one which I you know I use and I actually recently recorded this in a lesson on the app. You know just gratitude. Just thinking this is actually you know this particular maneuver is I believe comes from stoic philosophy.
I didn't actually get it from stoic philosophy but this this sort of use of negative imagination where you think of all of the bad things that haven't happened to you.
So if you're just you know if you're stuck in traffic driving to the job that you don't like and you're you're frustrated you can think of all the things that could happen to you right that haven't.
And if any one of them happened to you you would consider your prayers answered if you could just be returned to this moment right like you haven't been diagnosed with cancer.
You've got two young kids say you know you want to live to see them grow up and you could be the guy who today is going to find out you've got two months to live right and you have to then the next two months is spent just unwinding your worldly affairs right.
You're not that guy right that hasn't happened to you yet. That's just more thinking but it can have a profound effect. You can you can reframe your experience in a way that doesn't actually change anything material about your circumstance and it can let the light in.
Rule number two control your thoughts.
And this is where you know worry is almost always pointless because in each moment there's either something you can do to solve a problem or there isn't right now if there is something to do well then just do that thing right to solve the problem right.
If there isn't there's actually nothing to worry about like the worry adds nothing to that situation right.
So you're so you know if you have a brain tumor yes you need to go from one doctor to and probably to a second doctor for a second opinion and if you find the surgeon you want it and there's a whole process you're going to get an MRI.
You know all of it you're you're you're having to deal with a lot of yes objectively stressful things but I mean big picture we're all in this situation in life itself is a brain tumor.
We're all going to die. We're all we're all we're all going to go on this. We're going to get the full tour. Now for some of us you know some of us will be very lucky and it will be very orderly and free of pain and we'll be surrounded by everyone we love.
100 years old. Yeah it's just going to go perfectly and for some people it'll be chaotic and terrifying and short or long.
It's every permutation and I'm not denying that it's rational to have preferences there right. I mean like you know you do want the orderly loving you know and not untimely unraveling of it all.
Rather than the opposite but it's whatever is happening you have this moment and then you're thinking and you're and you're thinking about the future and you're thinking about the fact the past is the mechanism by which you will truly suffer in each moment.
Because it is in fact true to say that even physical pain is something around which you can develop an impressive ability to be a quantumist right.
And we and we also have you know we have you know for extreme pain we have painkillers I mean like happily we're living we're not living in you know 1700 where you know someone is just kind of sawing off your limb you know you know after the leeches didn't work.
So you know 99% of our suffering around everything you know even objectively horrible things like brain tumors is our thought about past and future is the regret and it's the story we're telling ourselves.
Rule number three, start valuing your time.
Now most of us do our best not to think about death but there's always part of our minds that knows this can't go on forever. Part of us always knows that we're just a doctor's visit away or a phone call away from being starkly reminded with the fact of our own mortality or of those closest to us.
Now I'm sure many of you in this room have experienced this in some form. You must know how uncanny it is to suddenly be thrown out of the normal course of your life and just be given the full time job of not dying or caring for someone who is.
But the one thing people tend to realize at moments like this is that they wasted a lot of time when life was normal. It's not just what they did with their time. It's not just that they spend too much time working or compulsively checking email.
It's that they cared about the wrong things. They regret what they cared about. Their attention was bound up in petty concerns that year after year when life was normal.
And this is a paradox of course because we all know this epiphany is coming. Don't you know this is coming? Don't you know that there's going to come a day when you'll be sick or someone close to you will die and you'll look back on the kinds of things that captured your attention.
And you'll think what was I doing? You know this and yet if you're like most people you'll spend most of your time in life tacitly presuming you'll live forever.
It's like watching a bad movie for the fourth time or bickering with your spouse. These things only make sense in light of eternity.
Rule number four, be fully present.
So much of what we're thinking is making us miserable. So much of it is unpleasant. So much of it is causing anxiety. You look at your to-do list. You've got 50 things on it. You just feel like the day is not long enough.
And that's a high class problem to have. There are worse problems. This is the state we're in and the obverse of that is when we're really just connecting with life in a joyful, creative, beautiful way.
Like when you look out the window and it's the most beautiful sunset ever and you are just looking at the sunset. You're fully connected with its beauty.
Those are all moments where you're losing this sense of self. But the difference between meditation and those moments is that you're not really aware of losing the sense of self in those moments.
You're not really aware of what is freeing about those moments. And you can't do it in other circumstances. I need the beautiful sunset. Just looking at your shoe isn't good enough for me.
But with meditation, I can actually look at your shoe in the same way that I look at the sunset. What's happening for most people is that they're waiting for the world to give them a good enough reason to just be present.
And to be present so fully that they lose their sense of self. That they're no longer behind their face just waiting for something good to happen.
Or figuring out how to change the experience enough so that, again, they're no longer at war. To a greater or lesser degree, we're always at war.
We're always fighting something. You're always noticing something wrong. You're feeling uncomfortable in your body. You're reacting to something that somebody did or you thought they did.
You're navigating a social encounter that seems off kilter. It's awkward and you're trying to figure out what to say. That sounded stupid. You're just being blown around.
And the moments where you really feel good are moments where there isn't a coming to rest. Where it's not about the past or future. It's not about half a second ago. It's not about half a second from now.
And the ultimate version of that entails the dropping of this sense of self.
Also, if you want to learn from other successful writers, check out my 254 Writers' Wisdom series. It's free. The link to join is in the description below.
Clock time is fine, but psychological time is when the future takes over your mind and your entire thought patterns are geared only towards future.
It's not enough to know what you want. You have to do what you want to be what you want.
Anytime I deviated from that love and went into something else, I just was so unhappy.
Rule number five, achieve mindfulness.
How do we unlock our consciousness or expand it in a positive way?
There's a sort of trivial versions of mindfulness and there's the deeper version. And the deeper version is really to understand the mechanics of your own mental suffering and put yourself in a position to cease to suffer unnecessarily.
You notice that you're lost in thought almost every moment of your life and much of your thinking has this mediocre character of causing you to worry about the future and regret the past.
And just feel a baseline disease with life. Whether it is just what it was like for me to drive here in traffic. Am I going to be late? Am I supposed to be here at 10 o'clock?
So much of our life is the steady hum of that kind of thinking. Not to mention the bigger concerns about disease and whether your child is sick. We're plunged into thought in each moment and we don't notice it.
And until you learn to be mindful, you can't notice it. You might have this abstract idea that, yeah, of course I'm thinking a lot of the time, but so what? What's the alternative? There is no alternative.
Each thought will arise and completely capture your attention and then you are hostage to the emotional and behavioral imperatives of that thought.
And it's necessary to some degree to be that way because we need thought. Thought is the way we organize our lives and form plans and understand what's happening.
Almost everything that makes us human is born of our capacity for abstract thought and planning and goal formation and all the rest. But it's possible to recognize thought as a stream of appearances in consciousness and to recognize that consciousness is the prior condition of their arising.
And when you can do that, you can actually break the link between thought and psychological suffering. So the thought is an anxiety-producing thought. You can notice this whole process where thought arises and you feel anxious and that feeling of anxiety in your body, once uninspected, begins to generate the motive for further thoughts along those lines.
So you're thinking about the thing that makes you anxious and because you're anxious, you're finding the anxiety intolerable. You've got resistance to feeling this feeling and you're thinking about, like, how can I get out of this?
And, like, clearly I've got a lot. I've got to change here. I'm going to start writing some things down on a checklist. And you're thinking without knowing that you're thinking and you're feeling the motive force of this emotion.
But once you can become mindful, which is to just be aware of what's arising in consciousness without judgment, without reaction, without resistance, to be able to notice anxiety as just a pattern of sensation in the body.
And then when you can do that, you can see that, first of all, it's not that bad.
I'm dying.
And under a different framing, it's a sensation that is often pleasant. The excitement you feel or even the anxiety you feel before you get on a roller coaster, if that's your thing, is something you're willing to pay to do.
Like, yeah, you want this thing. That's part of the experience.
Like skydiving.
Yeah, whatever. The thrill is a thrill because you felt some of that, right?
Rule number six, change your perspective.
Unless experience lasts forever, there's no point. It means nothing. So just try to map this onto your life.
Every good meal you've had, every pleasant experience as opposed to an unpleasant one, every relationship, none of it means anything because it ends.
A good movie is meaningless. It's no better than a bad movie because it ends.
This is a strange idea. Unless we disappear into infinity with experience, there's no difference between the most sublime happiness and the most abject suffering.
And I think when you actually try to connect with that intuition, it's strange and really is insupportable in our moment-to-moment experience.
We care very deeply about the character of our experience. In fact, it's the only thing we can care about.
And I think quite to the contrary, this notion of eternity, this notion of nothing matters here but it matters over the long haul in the afterlife because the bulk of our experience is after we die.
This religious idea actually robs life of its meaning. It doesn't bring meaning to life.
It renders meaningless all of the precious moments we have while alive. This is the only life we're certain of.
And it's continually ending. It not only ends in death but it ends in each moment and things change.
And that makes each moment precious. So you take an experience like if you're a new parent and you're carrying your child.
What you do, you pick your child up hundreds of times a day, it seems, and you never think that there's going to be a last time you do that.
At a certain point, your child's going to get too heavy to pick up. You don't pick up 15-year-olds for the most part.
At a certain point, you will have picked your child up for the last time. Now, we tend not to go through life thinking in those terms.
But if we did, if we realized that it's as though we're standing in front of a kind of a ticket machine at a deli counter and we're just pulling tickets, not knowing how many are in there.
And we just, at a certain point, you pull and you've got the last one in hand for every experience.
There'll be a last time you pick your child up and you will not have noticed that was the last time.
That makes life very precious and certainly death, the final ticket at the end of life, makes it all incredibly precious.
It could not be more precious and its preciousness is not predicated on it lasting forever as though such a thing could even make sense.
Rule number seven, live in the moment.
Do you think that there is an answer to that question, that meaning to one's existence can be found through a spiritual quest of the type that you talked about?
Yeah, I think it's the wrong question. It's just, it's a question that seems to create a space for an answer that now needs to be filled in and the fact that we can't fill it in perfectly is considered some kind of problem.
But I do think it's the wrong question because the meaning, you don't ask that, whenever you're having an experience that is deeply fulfilling and you're really just, you're not distracted by thought, you're not waiting for the next good thing to happen,
you're not looking over the shoulder of the present moment to see what's coming, you're just totally with whatever it is, you're not then worrying about what it means.
This is something, you have to do something in order to find that question interesting and the thing you're doing is less interesting than really being connected to the present moment.
And in the present moment, there's no, if you're not lost in thought and you're truly just surrendered to consciousness in the present moment, whether it's pleasant or unpleasant, there's no, you don't have to think of the grand design of your life.
Now it's not to say that there's, you can't ask big questions about the arc of your life, what you want your life to look at and what would be, if you look at what would be a great way to spend the next 10 years,
those are valuating questions that we can ask and plan for and all that's fine, but the meaning of existence, that's a...
Or reason for your existence, you see a reason for your existence.
But I almost never, to get up in the morning and get to the coffee pot, I don't need a reason other than I want coffee.
And basically the rest, most of life works that way and even the most profound moments work that way.
So when I'm holding my eight month old daughter in my hands and she smiles and I smile back and there's that moment of just, she's now like the cutest thing in the world.
I don't need to abstract away from that and say, well, what does this mean?
That's a failure to connect, that the answer to that question would help me overcome, presumably.
The implicit in that question is if we had an answer, well then life would be better, but why not just do the thing with your attention that would actually make life better?
Rule number eight, read.
I know there are ways that are recommended to read a book so as to extract the actionable information as quickly as possible from it.
I have never been an adopter of any of those ways and worse still, I basically read everything at the same speed.
So I read everything like it's scripture.
So if it's People Magazine in the waiting room of a dentist's office, I'm reading that at the same speed that I'm reading a work of philosophy or neuroscience.
And the big change of late, I guess this probably happened somewhere around 10 years ago, is that once I realized that there's functionally an infinite amount of information to consume.
It's doubling in the sciences every three to five years and there are literally thousands of good books that I will wish I had read but I will never get around to reading.
I've become a very fickle reader in the sense that I cut my losses very early.
The sunk cost fallacy has completely disappeared for me.
The idea that I've spent five hours or five days on this thing so I better just finish it.
That used to be my orientation with respect to reading books.
Now I'll discard a book just on a whim because I know there's an infinite amount of stuff I want to read.
I don't go into the table of contents and look at the structure of the book and then go to the index and then look at the topics.
I just start on page one and start reading and then when I get bored I stop.
Do with that life hack what you will.
Rule number nine, question everything.
Most of humanity even at this moment doesn't have the free attention to really think seriously about what it means to be happy.
You just look at the economic imperatives of most people in most situations.
It's not about really having the free attention to do whatever you want or what you would think at the end of the day would be most satisfying.
It's about survival, more basic needs.
You're living in a situation of stark political insecurity.
You're just worried about what sort of violence may happen in the street later today or what you may or may not say that could get you jailed.
It's crazy.
So much of human history has been just figuring out how to get strangers to cooperate reliably enough so that they have the free attention to explore the things we want to explore so that we can figure out why we're dying from diseases and then cancel them.
Just to be able to do science is a luxury.
This is where, as you probably know, I've spent a lot of time criticizing organized religion because historically and even currently so much of it is hostile.
So much of it is putting in place a real curiosity and a real search for answers, Iron Age fictions that just got codified in books that can't be edited.
In my view, the main tool we have to navigate now, and this has always been the case, but it's just more and more imperative that we realize this, the main tool is human conversation.
What every religion is is an insistence by a certain group of people that we anchor ourselves to a conversation that was held hundreds or thousands of years ago.
So it's like either you want to have the best ideas actionable and interpretable now, or you want to be hostage to what your great-great-great-great-great-great-great grandfather and grandmother thought was true about the nature of reality.
And if you go back far enough, you're talking to people who knew absolutely nothing that a sixth grader knows today.
And rule number 10, the last one before a very special bonus clip, is be grateful.
I noticed this at dinner the other night with my family. Everyone seemed to be in a fairly mediocre frame of mind.
We were all in some way disgruntled or stressed out. I had a million things I was thinking about, and I suddenly noticed how little joy we were all taking in one another's company.
And then I thought, if I had died yesterday and could have the opportunity to be back with my family, I thought of how much I would savor this moment right now.
And it totally transformed my mood. It gave me instantaneous access to my best self and to a feeling of pure gratitude for the people in my life.
Just think of what it would be like to lose everything and then be restored to the moment you're now in, however ordinary.
You can reboot your mind in this way, and it need not take any time. The truth is you know exactly what it's like to feel overwhelming gratitude for your life.
You are in an unusual situation. There are at least a billion people on earth at this moment who would consider their prayers answered if they could trade places with you.
There are at least a billion people who are suffering debilitating pain or political oppression or the acute stages of bereavement.
To have your health, even just sort of, to have friends, even only a few, to have hobbies or interests and the freedom to pursue them, to have spent this day free from some terrifying encounter with chaos is to be lucky.
Just look around you and take a moment to feel how lucky you are. You get another day to live on this earth. Enjoy it.
Now I've got a special bonus clip from Sam on how to focus on doing the things that matter that I think you're going to enjoy.
But before that, it's time for the three point landing questions. Let's go from just watching a video to taking action. Here we go.
Question number one, what are three things that you are grateful for today?
Number two, what's the biggest perspective shift that you need to make consistently?
And number three, where do you need to start valuing your time more?
Now if you like this video and you're going to start taking some action after it, give me a hashtag believe down in the comments as well.
What I'm spending my time doing is trying to engage honestly with interesting and consequential ideas.
So the Venn diagram I have, I don't think about it a lot, but when I think about retrospectively what I have been spending a lot of time doing,
I seem to keep finding the intersection of intellectually interesting ideas. They have to have some connection to science or philosophy.
It has to be the kind of thing that someone may want to think about anyway because they're just cool ideas.
So something like artificial intelligence. Very interesting to think about, but it's also hugely consequential, increasingly so.
And if we get it wrong, it will redound our misery if not extinction. So that's the center of the bullseye for me.
Something that's interesting, something that's consequential, something that the difference between getting it right and wrong is enormous.
So that's the landscape where I'm trying to continually focus my conversations.
And if you want to learn from another successful thought leader genius, check out the video right there next to me. I think you'll enjoy it.
Continue to believe and I'll see you there.